okay Emily
[Music]
okay yeah this is the best level okay we
got it we got a duck when the sign comes
don't don't do anything okay you see the
Sun it will come yeah good job Ken sad
finally that [ __ ] left yeah I can't see
it I'm still going in
[Music]
jen has to win he has a it's a condition
the Sun is coming the Sun is coming okay
you gotta jump you get a job you got a
job you got it yep I broke my back [ __ ]
Gotenks got my air jack fights like a
girl you pissing on me
really Ken you should not wait one [ __ ]
it it's a me city
great Kenny's tryharding as usual guys
hey everyone leafy here I'm going to
kill myself
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm coming gasps hey what it hey cam why
don't you why don't you come over here
where it's nice and wet
[Laughter]
hey I'm the winner
I like this
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] yeah man it's like a dog when
he crushes his ass
[Music]
they're dead they're out of it now all
right then
[Music]
yeah Oh looks like your boys in trouble
[Applause]
[Music]
exactly as planned
there the whole table salad ass whoa all
right that was gang beefs hope you bros
enjoyed check out mark Jack and Kenny if
you haven't already for some reason link
in the description and as always stay
toasty hi everybody
better money your hair's going crazy
yeah
[Music]